[Musique]
nous sommes à dix minutes du centre de
madrid
cachée entre des échangeurs d'autoroutes
et l'immense décharge régionale de la
capitale la can yade a real le plus
grand quartier illégal de roms
les madrilènes ignorent son existence
pourtant trente mille personnes vivent
ici
samedi midi la décharge va fermer pour
le week end
les derniers camions poubelles s'éloigne
l'entrée de la décharge
c'est le seul morceau d'asphalt du
bidonville et le terrain de foot
d'angelo et ses amis les ados sont les
premiers habitants de la canada à avoir
accepté notre caméra ici on sait pas
quoi faire
y a vraiment rien même pas un cybercafé
c'est nul
y'a pas de cybercafés ya rien on a
l'impression d'être en quarantaine on ne
peut pas sortir d'ici c'est vrai
angelo à 14 ans il est né ici tu peux me
montrer ta maison
oui venez je vous montre
[Musique]
c'est là ma maison on doit mettre de
l'eau dans les bidons c'est vraiment nul
lalo électricité et regarder comment
c'est fait regardez ces câbles moi je
fais un bep d'électricien
alors j'aurai bien que c'est n'importe
quoi cette installation quelquefois
l'eau arrive au robinet mais là ça ne
marche pas regardez alors on réchauffe
l'eau de la citerne dans la cheminée
angelo est l'aîné d'une famille de sept
enfants
son père est un maçon au chômage sa mère
s'occupe des plus petits pour angelo pas
de questions de ressembler à un enfant
des bidonvilles
il veut avoir l'air d'un ado comme les
autres pour ça il a ses astuces
je mets les sacs plastiques à cause de
la boue qu'il ya ici tous les autres
quartiers de madrid
t'es pas obligé de faire ça n'y a qu'ici
un jour il l'espère angelo partira de la
canada mais pour l'instant le bidonville
ne cesse de grandir chaque mois de
nouvelles familles s'installent dans des
maisons en dur ou dans des cabanes
surtout des espagnols mais aussi des
marocains et des sud américains
parmi eux aucun clandestin tous sont
recensés par l'état espagnol
les enfants sont scolarisés pourquoi ces
familles se résigne hôtel à vivre dans
la salubrité
la crise est-elle si aiguë en espagne
que fait l'état pendant trois semaines
nous avons filmé de l'intérieur cette
immense ville illégale aux portes de
madrid
[Musique]
manuel et mickaël viennent de
s'installer avec leurs familles à la
canada l'année dernière il avait encore
un appartement un travail et une vie qui
leur plaisait aujourd'hui au chômage ils
font comme beaucoup d'habitants de la
canada ils vivent de récupération ces
salles non c'est oui c'est seul et pour
manger on est bien obligé et vous
michael ça change de votre ancien
travail avant je ne savais même pas que
ça existait la récup
je n'avais jamais vu ça là j'avais un
travail stable j'étais surveillants
c'était autre chose
j'étais assis dans un bureau c'est parce
qu'on est dans le besoin qu'ont fait ces
manuels et mickaël veulent nous emmener
à vic alvaro le quartier populaire de
madrid où manuel habitait il ya encore
quelques mois avant je vivais ici c'est
ma maison
c'est ma mère là-haut ici moi j'adore
regarder la rue quel bonheur
c'est tout propre et le bar en face
c'est la vie normale quoi
entrez entrez
voilà c'était mon petit chez moi je
vivais ici avec ma femme et mon fils
mais c'était vraiment devenu trop petit
pour tout le monde alors je suis parti
dans le bidonville est comme ça sur le
balcon de l'appartement manuel se
souvient de sa vie passée
ici tu es tranquille tu fermes tu mets
ton chauffage très bien et les copains
les voisins
pour donner un toit sa petite famille
manuel a quitté l'appartement de ses
parents
cette autonomie lui a coûté son confort
et
[Musique]
quand on arrive on a l'impression
d'arriver dans un tas de merde mais bon
c'est d'ici que les deux amis se sont
connus il y a deux ans cet endroit était
encore un terrain vague
les deux pères de famille ont installé
leurs logements de fortune sans permis
de construire ni titres de propriété est
en pétard ça c'est ma maison ça fait dix
mois que j'habite là un appartement
normal ça vous aurait pu dire combien un
appart aujourd'hui ça coûte 100 milles
90 milles et cette maison cette maison
4000 5000 euros ici il y à l'électricité
et la lumière
oui l'électricité est détournée de
l'éclairage public et l'eau du réseau
municipal
si on est bien au frais chaud il nous
laisse filmer son intérieur quelques
minutes
mais très vite nous prie de sortir j'ai
honte vous savez
michael lui nous autorise à le suivre à
l'intérieur de son habitation une cabane
de bois et de toile qui l'a aussi
construite lui même après cela fait six
mois qu'il vit ici avec sa femme angela
et leurs deux petites filles
avant il louait un petit appartement où
ils logeaient tous les quatre quarts
michaëlle gagnet 1500 euros avec son
salaire de surveillants pas facile de
s'habituer à cette nouvelle vie surtout
pour angela la première fois que je suis
arrivé à mon mari je n'étais jamais allé
dans un bidonville
au début je pleurais la nuit je voulais
m'en aller d'ici à qui il fait froid
j'avais peur pour les petits j'avais
peur de tout c'est rare je dois cacher
la nourriture est assez rare venez voir
notre cabane regarder mais ça c'est le
lit où on dort chez la petite qui dort à
côté
cette cabane
regardez j'ai refait tout le soin c'est
vous qui l'avez reçu c'est moi qui ai
tout réparer j'ai remis du papier je
repeins pour tout cacher parce que
c'était vraiment dégoûtant et ça c'est
mon beau père qui me l'a offert comme ça
on a un peu de chose mais vous dites à
vos anciens voisins vous habitez non je
ne le dit pas mais là j'ai honte je dis
que j'ai acheté un bout de terrain je ne
dis pas que c'est un lino ville vous
avez vu comment c'est ici
à qui appartient le terrain sur lequel
manuel et michael se sont installés à la
région de madrid un terrain public
déclarées inconstructibles
carla canada real est un ancien chemin
de transhumance protégé pour des raisons
historiques
non seulement les habitants n'ont pas le
droit d'y construire leur maison mais
certains se livreraient même à un trafic
de parcelles dans le bidonville
le maire de rivas l'une des communes
voisines de la can yade a confirmé
l'existence d'un marché immobilier
parallèle les ventes des terrains qui ne
leur appartiennent pas qui sont
propriété de la ville de madrid
c'est terrible faire payer jusqu'à 20000
euros ce terrain il égale à 2 contre
jaune et pour y mettre leur cavale c'est
le compte de l'horreur nous avons
rencontré un habitant qui a été victime
de ce trafic
il s'appelle abdul c'est un maçon
marocain qui vit en espagne depuis 18
ans en 2006 la crise immobilière éclate
il perd son travail et ne peut plus
payer le loyer de son appartement
expulsé ils cherchent un toit pour
abriter sa femme enceinte de leur
premier enfant
un espagnol lui propose alors de lui
vendre un terrain sur la canne yade les
parcelles se vendent comme ça par
exemple j'ai acheté le terrain à
monsieur il n'y a même pas de papiers
sur lequel on écrit le montant de
l'argent qu'on a donné d'entendre
commencer nous les étrangers qui sommes
arrivés ici on ne comprend pas bien
parce qu'on n'a pas fait d'études oui
mais vous savez combien vous avez payé
j'ai vingt mille euros pour le terrain
vous savez ce que ça représente vingt
mille euros toutes vos économies
à quel moment non j'avais pas tout cette
j'ai dû emprunter à droite et à gauche
j'ai travaillé pour pouvoir me payer le
terrain
abdul avait construit ici une maison en
briques de 80 mètres carrés
mais en 2007 la justice a ordonné sa
démolition car elle était située sur un
terrain inconstructible
tout était en bris comme ça elles
étaient construites en briques
j'ai coulé un peu de béton par dessus
pour poser mon containers aujourd'hui
abdullah renoncer à reconstruire sa
maison par manque d'argent mais aussi
dans la crainte de voir revenir les
bulldozer à la canada il y a des
centaines de maisons en dur et des
milliers de cabanes en bois tout son
saoul ordonnance de démolition
décidément ce bidonville est une zone de
non-droit royaume de la débrouille et
des petits trafics
comme cette installation électrique
détourner des pylônes de haute tension
voisins attends je le branche la voile
on tire les deux fils branche nord dany
et ses voisins sont les électriciens du
bidonville justement en pleine
intervention sur leurs réseaux pirates
il ya combien de kilomètres de câbles
ici là tu vas mettre tous boutabout tous
reliés entre eux tiens là non je trouve
ces dépanneurs improvisés sont à la
recherche d'une coupure sur leurs
réseaux parallèles ils veulent état de
l'installation la réparation risque de
prendre du temps
combien maisons n'ont pas d'électricité
vingt maisons 20 maisons et depuis
combien de temps les 5h ce matin jusqu'à
maintenant il n'a toujours pas ça nous
arrive une semaine sur deux une voiture
de police passe à dix mètres de là sans
un regard pour le groupe de voleurs
d'électricité de temps en temps de la
police qui passent seulement quand
quelqu'un comme un délit mais et la
compagnie d'électricité publique
non ici de les tester bon allez les gars
on dit et là c'est bon
ça y est maintenant vous allez voir dans
ce câble passe plus de 20000 volts
daigne reconnecte son quartier au réseau
pirate en bravant le danger comme s'il
s'agissait d'un jeu vous avez gagné
d'années et il a gagné le championnat
oui j'ai gagné mais il fallait pas que
je gagne parce qu'honnêtement des
saveurs tombe en panne
ils vont m'appeler et voilà on applaudit
dany et ses voisins vol d'électricité
publique au mépris des règles de
sécurité les plus élémentaires et sans
aucune crainte de la justice dans cette
ville invisible où l'état n'apporte ni
électricité ni eau courante
il n'y a évidemment pas d'école les
enfants de la canada sont scolarisés
dans les villes voisines 15 heures c'est
la fin des cours
angelo et son copain ne prennent pas le
bus pour rentrer au bidonville
il préfère partir discrètement à pied on
ne dit pas aux autres et d'être né de la
kenya dar on dit qu'on est là notre
quartier
si on leur disait qu'on ait du
bidonville il ne nous parlerait même pas
parce qu'ils ont peur ils ont peur qu'on
dise que les gens de la canéda sont
malhonnêtes
sur le chemin du retour les garçons
s'arrête dans un cyber café pour
regarder des vidéos sur internet
comme tous les ados de leur âge
regarde celui là regarde ce qui fait
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas d'ordinateur à la maison
non ça coûte trop cher en général on
traîne ici jusqu'à 6h à peu près et
après on rentre à pied au moins deux
heures du coup on arrive à la maison
vers 9 heures du soir pour rentrer chez
eux
angelo et antonio longe l'autoroute et
passe à travers champs un détour de
plusieurs kilomètres en traversant le
bidonville
il pourrait arriver chez eux une heure
plus tôt vous ne mangez pas tout le
monde il non non il ya plein d'autres
jeunes crient ça nous fait peur il peut
me voler ou nous poignarder où nous tuer
et donc
donc on coupe à travers champs on coupe
parce qu'on veut pas passer par là bas
ils nous font peur se passe jamais par
là bas il est serein car tout par terre
plein de trucs assez j'ai pas confiance
21h les deux garçons arrivent enfin dans
leur quartier
[Musique]
le secteur 6 la zone qui effraie les
deux ados se trouve à 600 mètres de chez
eux
derrière ces murs en ruines se cachent
les deux clans de narcotrafiquants qui
se partagent le marché de la drogue dure
à madrid
ces voitures sont celles de
consommateurs mais aussi de dealers qui
viennent s'approvisionner ici
[Musique]
filmer ce quartier peut être dangereux
la police et l'agencé antidrogue
espagnols ont refusé de nous y emmener
on va voir si le camion centre de madrid
nous avons rendez vous avec manolo il
est volontaire pour une association
humanitaire avec ses compagnons il se
rend tous les jours dans le secteur 6 on
a les imperméables les verts des
sandwichs le bouillon juste pas là on
est prêt pour commencer la journée
ancien toxicomane manolo a bien connu la
kenya dar real aujourd'hui ils
distribuent de la nourriture aux drogués
de la zone il est le seul à avoir
accepté de nous accompagner sur place
car il tient à nous montrer l'enfer du
secteur 6
elle est annoncée au moment c'est plutôt
dangereux ils sont sous tension et
d'anticorps les dealers ont plus de mal
à revendre leurs doses
il ya de plus en plus de disputes entre
eux c'est un peu dangereux
on ne peut pas dire le contraire
vous
la caméra attention à droite
attention de ne pas déranger si je me
fie mémoire il n'y aura pas de problème
manolo nous demande d'être discrets car
nous passons devant des dizaines de
points de vente de drogue les kiosques
ils ont même leur enseigne devant chaque
entrée
des guetteurs qui préviennent de notre
passage
ben voilà
ici du matin au soir c'est un défilé de
voitures en mauvais état aux vitres
embuées à leur bord de trois quatre
passagers manolo les connaît bien
c'est quoi cette voiture c'est un kunda
fonde aussi on les appelle les taxis de
la mort vont dans le centre de madrid
un point de rendez-vous charge deux ou
trois toxicomanes et les taxis les amène
ici pour acheter leur drogue et il les
ramène dans le centre de madrid
là où ils les ont récupérés du top coat
d'eros le chauffeur gagne sa vie comme
ça chaque drogué p 3 ou 4 euros pour la
cour aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
chômeurs qui sont les kundé ross avec
leur propre voiture
joe cocker coach s pour gagner leur vie
[Musique]
nous tentons d'approcher ses coudes
d'eros en caméra cachée mais il refuse
de nous parler
traqué par la police est sous contrôle
des clans de la drogue
ces chauffeurs sont très méfiants leurs
voitures sont des lieux de consommation
ou leur passage et toxicomane s'injecte
leur dose de drogue
il risque la prison ferme manolo fini
par convaincre l'un d'entre eux josé un
ancien boucher échnage vous êtes fund
héros je suis content des rôles
il accepte de nous parler de son travail
à condition de ne finit sa voiture ni
ses passagers
je leur demande tu veux y aller ils me
disent oui oui j'ai besoin d'un taxi il
vous fait oui on le paie 5 euros
je les emmène à la décote sur la route
c'est là qu'ils achètent leur dose de
drogue et après je les ramène là où je
les ai pris en un jour tu peux te faire
250 300 euros il faut juste que déduire
les sauces c'est très dangereux
un jour ils ont essayé de me voler ma
voiture et m'ont pris le bras ils m'ont
bloqué par chance j'ai pu me dégager
heureusement que j'ai pris des cours de
full contact avec la crise il ya de plus
en plus de kun d'eros décline des
roseaux casio neil jours ils ont marre
d'être fauché il se met à faire ça les
taxis de la mort s'éloigne ils seront de
retour dans 20 minutes avec de nouveaux
passagers certains toxicomanes ne
repartent plus de la canada trop
dépendants pour travailler ils n'ont pas
d'argent pour en sortir
ils vivent au jour le jour stérilise des
sorts un usager trouvait à terre pour
les revendre et se payer leur dose
c'est à eux que manolo distribuer la
nourriture de son camion
daniel est l'un de ces toxicomanes
échoué dans le bidonville
malgré sa carrure imposante ce géant de
2 mètres vit dans l'angoissé des
agressions quotidiennes et des
règlements de comptes entre dealers
ici à chaque instant tout peut arriver
est-ce que j'ai peur bien sûr que j'ai
peur
c'est dangereux très dangereux mais
grâce à dieu et à ces gens qui viennent
nous aider
vous êtes fort oui j'ai encore la force
mais à rester ici on perd toutes ses
forces
j'espère qu'un jour il changera d'avis
et qu'il viendra avec mais il changera
de vie de situation un jour sûrement
j'aimerais que j'y pense souvent mais
c'est le diable qui me retient
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
allez en voir l'ami daniel nous a confié
qu'il dort à la canada depuis quatre ans
la nuit il se réfugier ici
ils cherchent un coin coin sous une
pierre et ils dorment là de se faire
mordre par les reins je crois que c'est
la limite où un être humain peut arriver
à 200 mètres de là les clans de la
drogue ont pignon sur rue cette zone de
la canada ressemble à une avenue
commerçante lieu d'achat pour les
consommateurs mais surtout stock où
viennent se fournir les dealers de la
capitale sur ces images de la police
espagnole
leur dernière intervention dans une
maison de grossistes un véritable bunker
y pénétrer il faut franchir quatre ou
cinq portes blindées
ces maisons sont toutes reliées entre
elles par des souterrains
les stocks de drogue s'évanouissent
avant que les brigades n'arrive ce matin
larmes la police a saisi le stock d'une
journée de revente dans ces conditions
d'insécurité et d'insalubrité extrême
pas étonnant que de nombreux habitants
de la cagne ada rêve de s'en aller
tous les soirs le bus de ramassage
scolaire ramène les enfants de deborah à
la canada donne moi la main
[Musique]
mais bora a plus de chance que beaucoup
de ses voisins elle vit avec sa famille
dans une vraie petite maison de 70 m²
acheter 8000 euros il y à 50 ha les
autres apprennent ici à la canada c'est
difficile d'avoir une maison propre
oui parce qu'on vit ici avec la boue la
terre la poussière et en plus j'ai un
saule blanc avec tout ça il faut laver
trois fois par jour parce que sinon
c'est l'enfer avant la crise deborah
était caissière dans un supermarché
julio son mari à un travail illégal
hagist mais ils peinent à boucler les
fins de mois de sa famille allait un
jour au lido c'est le plus petit qui
commence allez lens il ya la kenya dar
dans le monopoly
non non ça c'est le centre de madrid des
sols les quartiers chics des rues du
centre de madrid où deborah rêverait
d'habileté elle a fait des dizaines de
demandes de logement hlm
aujourd'hui elle est lasse d'attendre je
vais aller voir les immeubles la barre
là elle nous entraîne 1 500 mètres de sa
maison
car elle veut nous montrer quelque chose
qui la dépasse
[Musique]
là bas il ya des dizaines d'immeubles
vides qu'ils ne peuvent pas vendre parce
que les gens n'ont pas d'argent les
banques de fonds crédit à personne là il
ya plein de gens qui vivent dans des
conditions pas possibles et à 2 3
kilomètres
tous ces immeubles neufs inoccupés c'est
une honte
[Musique]
toboggans les enfants au 'parisien'
square ça vous plaît
oui j'adorerais
autant d'appartements vides alors qu'on
est tellement nombreux à la canada
pourquoi ne viendrait pas s'installer là
et s'ils ne font rien qui ne trouvent
pas une solution de relogement pour nous
tous c'est ce qui va arriver on va venir
là et qui sera responsable
en attendant deborah rentrer dans son
bidonville
poussé par la crise à rester dans
l'illégalité comme ses 30000 voisins
[Musique]